A, okay, I need your help with this next segment.
I really don't know what to make of it and
I'm coming to you because I want to hear what
you think, so let me set it up.
It's not a secret that former New York city
mayor and possible Trump lawyer, we don't
know if he's still Trump's lawyer, Rudy Giuliani,
he has concerned many people with his excessive
drinking of alcohol.
There were a bunch of prior reports that at
one point people around Trump were trying
to prevent Rudy from doing nighttime appearances
on Fox news and on other networks because
he would frequently go to dinner and then
drink too much and then you would show up
to the interviews disheveled and not making
any sense.
Several people sent me the same video, which
we're going to look at shortly of a Rudy Giuliani
appearance two days ago on Fox news.
And what's very interesting about this one
is that most people wrote to me saying, Rudy
seems drunk, his glasses are crooked.
Both eyes look weird, especially his left
dye who, which kept being half close throughout
the interview.
His reflexes seem slowed.
Most people were talking about alcohol, about
this interview, but I heard from two people,
one of whom as far as I know is not a medical
professional, but one who is a medical professional
who said, David, this is a daytime interview.
Rudy seems to drink at night.
This struck the doctor that emailed me more
like some kind of opiate use of some kind
of merely speculation to be clear.
Uh, but from a medical professional who has
not personally examined Rudy Giuliani, but
lean does the say, let's take a look.
I want to hear from you because it, in my
view, it's inconclusive.
Let's look at some of the clips.
Let's listen to these and I want to hear from
you.
Do you think anything is going on here?
If you're listening, you're mostly listening
for that sort of slowed delivery.
If you're watching, you will see Rudy look
sort of strange when he wears the glasses
that are crooked.
His eyes are closing in a way that seemingly
is beyond his control.
It's all very weird.
Let's take a look at clip number one.
Uh, who want visas to come to America to testify
about barista.
What would they say about barista and Hunter
[inaudible]?
Well, you know, uh, it's real simple.
This, this case is a, uh, this case had been
real simple from the day that Joe Biden confessed
to committing bribery back in January of 2018.
And the council on foreign relations didn't
note anything about it, although he said precisely
what was attributed to president Trump a year
and a half later that caused all sorts of,
uh, basically, uh, they'll prove that he committed
bribery.
The crime of bribery is offering something
of value to a public official for official
action.
OK, here's what Joe Biden says he did.
He offered him a $1 billion loan guarantee.
He threatened with a $1 billion loan guarantee.
So at this point, other than the eyes closing,
he's sort of repeating himself.
He's licking his lips a lot, kind of the circuitous
storytelling and lots of pauses.
It's not anything totally obvious to me.
Cut to a few minutes later in the interview
and it starts to get weirder.
I admit by now you'll notice Rudy sort of
swaying left to right as he talks left, right,
right.
As that left eyes seems even more closed up.
Well, claims he claims that we had a meeting
with the president at the Hanukkah party in
December of 2018.
Somebody should remind Lev that there were
five witnesses, including his, uh, his good
friend, Igor Fruman, who all say categorically
untrue, provable by records.
He's trying to make himself very important.
We never had that meeting with the president.
Now it continues.
And in this next section, the swaying back
and forth continues the eyes closing continue.
But now Rudy's voice does seem to get a little
strange, almost like a version of vocal fry
and he takes on a stranger demeanor plus some
strange sniffing that you might pick up on.
Okay.
Real quick.
He had every right to talk to him.
He, in fact, it would have been his duty to
do so.
I don't even, I have no idea why this lawyer
is creating these additional problems for
Lev.
They're not problems for me because there's
so many witnesses and documents to prove he's
lying.
That's why I hate to see, sure.
I do this for a living and I hate to see a
lawyer do this to somebody.
Okay.
You said it's not going to hurt you.
Are you afraid, mr mayor, that you could be
indicted?
Oh wow.
How awful.
How long have you known me?
I've known you several years.
You take, I'm afraid.
I don't know.
I get afraid.
Well, I did the right thing.
I represented my client in a very, very effective
way.
I was so effective that I've discovered a
pattern of corruption that the Washington
press has been covering up for three or four
years.
I dunno.
I think this is inconclusive and you know,
if one person had sent this to me, I probably
wouldn't even be bringing it to you, but because
five people contacted me about it, three saying
he seems drunk to saying they think it's opiates,
one of those two who's a medical professional.
I want to bring it to you.
I think it is interesting that people who,
as far as I know have nothing to do with each
other, wrote to me about the same thing, saying
similar, but not exactly the same thing in
terms of their analysis.
I'm curious what you think about the drinking
at night is well known.
This was a daytime interview.
Let me know your take on it.
You can find the entire interview online.
Leave a reply if you are watching on YouTube
or send me a tweet at Dee Pacman if you otherwise
want to let me know your thoughts.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
A lot of behind the scenes pictures means
upcoming previews and a lot of different things.
David Pakman show
on Instagram.
Follow us.